Sudáfrica dice que su cuarta ola puede
haber pasado los nuevos datos muestran
que las infecciones por coronavirus se
redujeron la semana pasada en casi un
30% en comparación con el anterior
mientras que los ingresos hospitalarios
disminuyeron en ocho de las nueve
provincias a mediados de diciembre con
el aumento de la variante Omicron el
país llego a tener unos 26000 casos
diarios
según los expertos Omicrón ha alcanzado
el punto álgido con manifestaciones
clínicas que no han provocado ninguna
alarma en la situación hospitalaria
mind las condiciones permiten que se
levanten el toque de queda
el último día del año al tiempo que las
autoridades eliminado la restricción de
movimiento de medianoche y han vuelto a
permitir la venta de alcohol una hora
antes se limitan además las reuniones a
1000 personas en interiores y a 2000 al
exterior aunque solo se ha registrado un
leve aumento de muertes durante el pico
de Omicron se mantiene la obligación de
llevar mascarilla en los espacios
públicos la nueva variante del
coronavirus se identificó por primera
vez a fines de noviembre en Sudáfrica y
Botswana ahora está presente en más de
100 países